- I remember when I was young,
hearing horror stories about
a dentist who would give kids
a little pink pill that would
turn their entire mouth pink
and highlight all the spots
that they missed while brushing.
So I went on the internet
and I found them.
Actually I found 250 of them.
What better place to try one of these
than on YouTube where hundreds of people
can laugh at me and make
fun of me in the comments,
so I figured we should
give one of these a go.
Okay this is the tablet, this is my mouth,
and let's do it.
Tastes pink.
How long do I do this for?
- [Man] 30 seconds.
- Alright.
It's purple now.
Look at that, look at
that, look at this shit,
I'm a fucking pro, dentists, get at me,
so that's what it would look like
if you did a pretty good job brushing
and thank you, thank you, thank you,
but there's gotta be
some people around here
who think they're really
good at brushing but,
are actually pretty bad.
Let's find some gross ass teeth.
- My usual dental routine, I
floss and then I brush my teeth
- I brush my teeth every
night before I go to bed.
- I scrub really hard, I'm
like, I go ham on my teeth.
- Sometimes I just don't
brush my teeth at all
'cause I'm just tired and lazy.
- Dental disclosing tabs?
- Sounds like something
you put in your mouth
after you get herpes.
- They show you were, like,
your teeth are dirty, right?
- This looks like an Ecstasy pill,
what are you guys giving me?
- Alright, let's do this.
- I'm like terrified to do this.
(soft music)
- Do I have to chew it up first?
- Tastes like bubblegum.
(soft music)
(spitting)
- Ew.
- I just spit purple saliva.
- Alright moment of truth.
- I can't wait, I'm seeing
the preview it's so bad.
- Shit.
(laughing)
- Looks kind of like I missed
a lot on the bottom side.
- I got a little bit more in
the crevices on the bottom.
- I don't see a lot of bad spots.
- I probably say like the top of my teeth
looks like it needs a
little bit more cleaning.
- Hmm.
(laughing)
- Does that mean my tongue's dirty too?
- I'm really surprised.
It doesn't look like I got everything.
- I'm just like surprised
that it's not everywhere.
- I mean it was a little helpful
it makes me think that like
I'm doing things right, you know,
it doesn't look catastrophic.
- If there's one thing I'd like to say
to my dentist right now, I'm sorry
I'll do better, don't tell my mom.
- To my future dentists I am really sorry,
at least I give you the
business (laughing).
- This video's definitely
NSFD, Not safe for dentists.
(laughing)
(soft music)